here we go
yo it's wild 94-1 man bootleg kev ready
set ready got the homie erica rock in
the building and we got a special guest
last night sold out show here in town
man machine gun kelly what's good fan yo
what up kev hells how you been man how
are you living really good just uh
back on the road my foot's not broke
anymore kinda i know i think i think i i
think uh last time i saw you a little
under a year ago we were talking about
um how you successfully knocked down
rachel starr
which which you know i'm still jealous
about yeah um but you know since then i
you put out the black flag tape this is
like my favorite project i've done i saw
you describe it as kind of like your
your unofficial sophomore album yeah man
that was i'm like there's so many songs
on there i was bummed that i didn't sell
right
or like not sell rather but like give to
the
gift to like radio or something like
there was like certain songs like the
rise against cover we did i felt was
just like
inside there was a lot of joints on
there like even peso with mimi can push
up i thought that was gonna i thought
that was gonna go
i remember i played it on the air of
phoenix i was like man this is this
could be the that's what i thought i was
like
i still hear i still hear some dj spin
in the club when i walk in and it always
goes but it just independently like
didn't really do its thing so even
though like the visuals that you have
off of that tape man everything was put
together yeah but like i but overall
though that tape was really successful
for me and really like pushed my whole
touring
you know game a whole nother level and
it took like just the live
instrumentation on my band to a whole
nother level so now i think when people
see us they see that
it's meant to be played in a stadium
rather than
you know stadiums and theaters and
amphitheaters and that's like the venues
we play now so it's exciting
really well too oh yeah black flag was
such a good look for us the song i
thought that really was going to go that
i thought the ratchet record with you
and all the dudes yeah that was such an
ill right
strip club heavy we still played at the
stream my god i was like yo this is
you guys dropped it right when ratchet
was hot
and we we that's like yeah that was the
tour bus favorite yeah man that's late
night that's where you you grab the uh
the thoughts bring them on the bus play
that record and see what happens
um so uh you're doing the est est fest
uh is this the second year yeah it's our
second annual festival
how is the vibe of this festival because
you know icp has their gathering of the
juggalos yeah it is crazy you're doing
your thing now in ohio um how is it man
this year seems like it's gonna be
pretty tight i think this year is gonna
be pushing a nice ten thousand maybe
it's gonna be big and it's just and it's
but it's dope because it's not this
isn't like a tournament you're not
talking like a huge field you're talking
about a campground right you know what i
mean so everyone comes and they camps
or camp not camps
they come and they camp for three days
and it's just an amazing weekend in in
in a state that really you know doesn't
really get much shine for much so we
brought this festival to ohio and um
last year i remember this this cool
story was this this girl from norway
flew out
by herself
and she linked up and est is our is our
fan base and uh
so there's some some some est fans like
reached out to her and she because she
was looking for like you know how to
move around and all this like that and
some est fans reached out for tour she
came to america um was picked up from
the airport by a fan
um got to stay in fans tents and
everyone was stoked to have her and they
welcomed her to america really cool
yeah totally family vibe man and uh so i
it was just it's just amazing you know
we have like pancake stands for
breakfast at the festival just great
great pancakes by the way um a lot of
cool a lot of cool stands my tattoo
artist that does my tattoos um he's out
there two 200 fans oh nice uh you know
we had to cut it off after 200.
you know we allowed 200 fans to get
tattooed by him some lace-up tattoos
that's nice um
and then you know the the shows and
saying i always do like a two-hour set
and then this is a long set yeah yeah
but and it's crazy because
right there it's crazy because you would
see like like the mainstream with cr
just like me and be like how i couldn't
sit there for two hours because i don't
really know too many of your songs but
to these kids and and to myself you know
these are like hits so like every song
that we drop for two hours straight is
gonna be like every lyric song they know
it all you do the album cuts every you
know a lot of times when when someone
sees you know a regular set you can't
squeeze in like the super like yeah you
know gems that people rock with but
something like that you know you can
yeah yeah yeah just uh came up with that
stuff with steve aoki oh dude yeah free
the madness i recorded that five times
and i hated him for it every time we
were record the record he would be like
all right well this sound is like out in
an edm right it's not it's not it's not
it's not going to be hot anymore so we
need to reconstruct it so he we did it i
recorded probably five times over a span
of like a year and a half jesus and then
we shot all that for once
for one song and i wrote the actual
verse in the whole song when i was stuck
outside of his house because he had to
go to europe
and while we were in the middle of a
session and he was like i have to go to
europe just okay cool then i'm like i'm
like all right well no no worries like
i'll just tell my ride to come give me
my ride with dre
so dre and then like
they could we like whatever happened
would go out lost in it yeah
and um so he had to leave so i was like
i'll just wait out here is there a lot
of benihana stuff at his house no he's
like not even he doesn't even know how
to really it's crazy and
so i'm like i'm out there and i wrote
the whole thing on this curve waiting
for a ride and then um yeah then we shot
the video like eight months before the
video came out video came out real big
yeah so i'm like i'm still looking a lot
younger in the video than i actually
look now because i we shot it so long
ago so i was just like waiting like man
is it has anything to happen with the
song and then it came out and it's like
one of our favorites in concert